let's talk about
important sampling because we have
always been talking about
uniform distribution it's you will see
that it's not
usually it's not a really great idea
to assemble any function with the
uniform distribution
and what i usually what i am usually
looking for
is that i have a function that i would
like to reconstruct and i have a fixed
sample budget
and from this project like x samples or
x samples per pixel
i would like to get the best estimation
possible now we have written the formula
for important sampling
this important sampling was before when
i divided by the p
of x because i don't only have the f i
will also take into consideration with p
and there i can plug in an arbitrary
sample distribution it can be uniform
distribution it can be a gaussian
distribution
it can be many things
now take a look at this
just a second
thanks
okay so i would like to integrate this
function which is
the blue line so it's a spiky function
and imagine that the green bars is the
actual sampling distribution that i use
it doesn't look like a good idea can
anyone tell anymore
exactly that's true so the green bars
are too low
too high on the right side and too low
in the middle
why is this a problem
it's not representing the actual
distribution exactly so it has to
represent the actual distribution
that we would like to sample why
well let's skip a few slides okay
so if the function takes a higher value
at some regions
this means that if i miss out on the
reconstruction
of this region then my error is going to
be higher
so what you could say is that if there
is like a gaussian function or a spikey
function i would want to put more
samples
where the spike is because that's a
large area
so if i can reconstruct this large area
better
i'm doing much better as if i would be
something the parts that are actually
have very small intervals so the flat
regions that are almost zero so let's
put more samples to the regions where
the function is actually larger
and if we do this correctly then what
we're doing is called important sampling
so what we're looking for is that i have
these green bars and these green bars
should match
the blue function
important sampling again i am looking
for
the expected value of f over p so i
divided and multiplied
with p of x in the expected value
formula
and the question is what should be the p
that i plug in here
so this can be the uniform distribution
on av or it can be an arbitrary
distribution
what would be a good distribution
usually what is proportional to the
function so if the function is large
somewhere
the sampling distribution has to sample
that region often so it also
also should be larger if it's small in
different regions then it also
also should be small and this also says
that if there are regions where the
function is zero i don't want to put
samples there
at all because there's nothing to
reconstruct the curve below
the function is zero
and we will deal with constructing
functions like that but for now
imagine that i have in my hand a
function
that is representative of the interval
now
we have talked a bit about this so this
better
this this should give me quite a bit of
an advantage because
otherwise it's not work so this is a
rendered image with no importance
something that look closely you will see
now
results will import something so fixed
sample budget
it was running for the same amount of
time
and this is the difference that you can
obtain with simple importance
so this means wherever there is more
light i will put more samples and the
darker regions i will need left of it
with my samples let's take a look at
another example
you can see how this how noisy this
region
is next to the car and with the
important sampling
this is accounted for much better
now we are finally at the moment where
we can
attempt to solve the rendering equation
so this
infinite dimensional singular this
problem child
that is so difficult that it seems
at first that no one should ever block
butter to even try it
but now it seems that we have every tool
in order to solve it
so just again the intuition the left
side
after the equality sign means that there
are objects that implied
light sources if you will and this i
have to account for
but this is not the only source of light
as the as these objects emit light
then these will hit other objects that
reflect
this amount of light so this means that
i emit an amount of light
and i also reflect an amount of incoming
light
taking into consideration also light
attenuation
and the vrdf which is the material
properties
of the object that i have at hand so
let's evaluate this
through monte carlo integration so again
the formula
i am sampling f over p this is
equivalent
of integrating f of x from a to b
now what is f f is what you see up here
on the right this whole thing
uh sorry just the integral part and p
will be something so i just substitute
the very same thing in here on the right
side so incoming light
times the brdn times the light
attenuation vector
and there is going to be a p which is
now
a sampling probability for outgoing
direction so this means that i hit an
object
and i need to have a choice which
outgoing direction should i assemble
where should i continue in which
direction in my ring
so this is going to be one direction of
the hemisphere this is the monte carlo
estimator
for the actual integral and let's
imagine that
we are trying to solve this for a
diffuse object so the diffuse brdf is
rho over pi normally it was one over pi
y how can the prdf be just a number
well easy the perfect diffuse material
means that
all possible outgoing directions have
the same probability
if i hit this cable if it would be
perfectly diffused we talked about the
fact that this is actually glossy but if
it would be perfectly diffused
like lightning i hit it somewhere and
the outgoing direction can be
anywhere on this illumination hemisphere
they all have the same problem what does
row mean
rho is the albedo of the material
because if i say one over pi
this means that every ray that comes in
will have an outgoing grade
so this object would be completely
it wouldn't absorb completely wide it
wouldn't absorb any alternatives
most objects are not like that so
this absorption is wavelength dependent
and we can represent this as now how
does the equation look like
i just substituted dou over pi for the
vrdf
so it seems that we know everything in
this one
just the incoming gradients so what do
we do
with this sampling distribution when we
hit this diffuse object
we send out samples and we try to
collect the incoming gradients
which is the li with this sampling
distribution
and the question is for this case what
would be a good sampling
probability function to sample the
diffuse
vmdf now what we said is that this p
the denominator should be proportional
to
the numerator now l i we don't know
this is some some part that we cannot
really estimate because i would have to
send many samples out on this hemisphere
to know exactly how much light is coming
in
but by the time i get to know how much
light is coming in i've done the
sampling so then
i am not interested in the sampling
distribution because i have a converged
image
so this part will leave out from the
important sampling this we cannot handle
as of now
but this row over pi times cosine of
theta
we can't deal with so let's imagine
this sampling distribution which is
cosine of theta over pi
and the goal of this is that these
people will kill each other i have a
cosine theta times the numerator and the
denominator
and the same with pi so this only
so only this part will remain there i
could technically also put
the albedo of this given material in the
sampling distribution but
that's but let's be general for now so
in the end
i have this simple equation
look at this this is what is going to be
the solution of this
infinite dimensional integral what it
says
is that i'm going to send samples on
this hemisphere and i'm going to average
it because in the end i defined by
that's it
and then if you do something like this
and you add the volumetric part
then you can render margarita from the
game of thrones